foreign
what's the most useful thing I could
share with your audience that I've
learned like in the last seven years
since we last spoke the thing that's
made the biggest difference in my life
as a superpower a big huge change so to
me it's been in short skepticism
so if you wonder why I'm so happy why
I'm thriving why I seem to be doing well
to me it's a lot of my happiness comes
from this world view that is radical
doubt it's skepticism and so I'm going
to give this the shorthand of calling it
useful not true but
the visual for it is that moment at the
end of The Matrix movie when Neo
realizes like those aren't bullets this
is just code remember all the bullets
come his way is like oh wait right like
none of these rules apply to me that's
deep skepticism
it's empowering it's liberating and so
what I'm gonna do for a few minutes
including a little stories is to play
Morpheus to help emancipate the
listeners so yes I call this useful not
true yeah there we go number one so okay
I'm gonna tell you the four bits first
and we'll use that to kind of make sure
that we come back to this so like number
one almost nothing is objectively true
number two beliefs are placebos so you
got to believe whatever works for you
now number three rules and Norms are
arbitrary games that can be changed I'm
preaching with converted that one and
number four refuse ideology you need to
accept ideas individually
there's the structure so number one so
almost nothing is objectively true
so here's what's true my hand is on the
table
but what's not true is it's good to do
everything in moderation here's what's
not true
family is everything here's what's not
true my mother abandoned me here's
what's not true AI is the future
so all of these things
people say them as if they're true or
even when people make an excuse like you
know I would be more successful if it
weren't for my family you know or my
location or whatever people say these
things as if they're an indisputably
true fact but to me
the only thing that's true are the
things that both a cat and an alien
or let's say a cat and an octopus would
agree on
if I come up with so many children's
books ideas in this conversation the
alien and the octopus because it makes
you realize that everything else is just
mental interpretation right like there
we go this is on the table this is true
yeah but everything else including watch
this one am I flipping you off right now
like am I angry at you right now just
give me the middle finger yeah sorry I'm
holding up my middle finger with the
back of my palm towards him
even if people say things like I hate
you does it mean that they hate you no
it just
they said three words that's all that
actually happened their mouth said these
words everything else is an
interpretation or a projection right so
we have to consider why people are
saying these things if you start to
think why they said something
it helps to dispel it you can say oh you
know what they're probably just
believing whatever supports the emotions
that they want to feel right now right
so if somebody has a belief
that family is everything
maybe that was something they told their
kids because they want their kids to
take care of them when they're older so
they want their kids to believe their
families everything but they have a
self-serving reason to believe that yeah
possibly subconscious right right right
oh so I'm so glad you said this have you
heard about the split brain Stories the
people yes okay why did you get up do
you have a glass of water that type of
stuff can can I tell you yeah so
this is so important to understand
these are crazy
so bananas and we'll start with the
other one since you know that one there
was no no but the audience doesn't come
up no no but we'll do both but during
brain surgery the patient needs to stay
awake in some yeah and so there was a
woman I don't know the details of this
it was on econ Talk podcast during brain
surgery they were poking around in there
and suddenly the woman started laughing
the patient started laughing and they
asked why are you laughing and she said
like oh well it's just it's really funny
the way that that curtain is hanging and
she really thought that the reason she
was laughing is because that's the way
the curtain was hanging but it was
actually because they were poking and
stimulating yeah and so the split brain
patients are some people who's left and
right hemispheres of their brain are not
connected so they've done tests on these
people to
say into their right ear
please get up and open the window
and they'll get up and open the window
and then they'll ask their left ear or
maybe it's their eye
why did you open the window and they'll
say oh it was just a it was a little
cold in here I hope you don't mind and
they really sincerely to the core
thought that's the reason they opened
the window yeah and there are a couple
more examples of this you know a message
shown to one eye and they did something
then they asked the other eye why did
you do that and every time the people
make up a reason they don't know they're
making it up they give a reason why they
did that and they feel completely
confident that that is the reason why
they did it yeah so to me this is the
most beautiful example like we actually
don't know so talk about deep skepticism
radical doubt
you shouldn't even believe anything you
tell yourself even in your private diary
when you're saying I'm not happy in this
location or I can't do this because of
that or I'm mad at so and so
you need to ask yourself like okay that
might not be true just because I'm
saying it in my opportunity so number
two beliefs are placebos
so two people in the same boat one can
say this sucks and another one can say
this is great
um but neither one is true
no beliefs are true in fact you know the
little story of Richard Branson before
there was Virgin Airlines you've heard
the tale that like he was at an airport
and a flight to somewhere was canceled
where I was delayed and yeah and
everybody's grumbling ah this sucks and
so he kind of went to the 20 people that
were angry and said hey if I Charter a
plane will you guys split the cost and I
said yeah so everybody else was angry he
looked at the same situation and said
this is great and he you know that was
kind of the launch of Virgin Air no not
launch you know what I mean Apprentice
of Genesis Genesis nice word
so no beliefs are true when we say I
believe
it's an indicator that what we're about
to say next is not true or not
evidence-based right not true sorry I'm
just I'm just yeah having fun have fun
yeah not evidence-based yeah because we
don't say I believe in potatoes
because speak for yourself
because there's a potato we don't need
to say it because there it is it exists
so I think that whenever we say I
believe such and such it indicates that
whatever we say next is not true it's
kind of like when science is at the end
of a Field's name generally it's not
science not always but very often that's
not the case I can think of a few
exceptions Neuroscience computer science
but very often when science gets
appended to something it's like oh thou
doth protests too much yeah it's so
since no beliefs are true
I think this is liberating to realize
that you can just choose whatever belief
works for you now that helps you be who
you want to be this is like this is
about personal empowerment it's a little
bit hacking yourself if a certain belief
will help you be who you want to be
right now you don't need to keep
believing it tomorrow you could believe
it for three minutes or three days or
you know the rest of your life
you're going to find what you look for
so if you choose to believe something
you'll find evidence to support your
belief of anything right so the number
three is that rules and Norms are
arbitrary games so this is the one where
I can't help but think of
you know your introduction to the world
in four hour work week giving so many
wonderful examples of how you don't have
to accept the world's Norms yep you know
for sure but it's funny how many times
the rules of the world are stated as if
they're absolutely true like all
applicants must submit their application
through the usual channels and wait to
hear from us or to be an expert in your
field you should have an advanced degree
from a university
but someone made up these rules and most
people follow those rules but they're
not true they're just not absolutely too
so I think that realizing they're not
true gives you an incredible Advantage
because you realize you can make up the
rules so this is that Matrix moment
where the bullets are flying Avenues he
goes wait a minute this is just code
yeah somebody made this up but I don't
need to run this program